his book where comic book I guess is
what you can absolutely call it cuz it
is that Mycroft Holmes and the
apocalypse handbook is available now and
for those in the Los Angeles area you
can be at his event at Barnes & Noble at
the Grove this coming Thursday at 7:00
Eastern Time
he is the all-time leading scorer in the
history of the NBA he is Kareem
abdul-jabbar great to see you sir thanks
for being here
nice to be here thanks for having you
bet so I'll start with the question I
asked you all fair interesting times huh
very much so and never thought I'd see
it quite like this but here we are and
you know we it means that we have work
to do and we have to straighten a few
things out what did you think of the
president's comments on Friday night in
relation to the NFL players who are
kneeling and saying that he would love
to see an NFL owner tell a player that's
kneeling get that son of a [ __ ] out of
here you're fired what do you think of
that I thought that was a an absurd
statement and certainly it's ridiculous
the players have the right to express
their feelings about what they see
happening in our country and some of
these things are very alarming and
people have to talk about it and discuss
it and hopefully you know we these are
things that we can fix but unless
there's some some discussion they won't
get fixed so I do want to handle what
others are saying and I guess a more
nuanced fashion than the president that
they are then saying to the president
thank you for saying this and that is
the idea that somebody is using the flag
as a form of protest by kneeling in
front of it during the national anthem
what would you say to folks who have
that stance figure oh well you know I
understand what they mean if they if
they perceive some slight to the nation
and to the flag I would appreciate what
they're doing I don't think that the
people who are doing this during the
national anthem are trying to insult our
country they are trying to provoke
people's conscious to understand that
things aren't right and there's a very
serious situation that needs to
dealt with you know that that is the way
that the legal justice system and the
police treat black Americans that
there's an issue there that has been a
problem and we need to deal with it well
Jim Brown has said that he he doesn't
like the kneeling in the national anthem
and and would advise NFL players not to
do it
Kaepernick in particular what do you
think about that Kareem well you know
that's his opinion and he's certainly
entitled to it I don't think really that
that's the issue the issue is how black
Americans are being treated by the legal
justice system everything else is
superfluous to that everything else is
is just people trying to deflect
discussion of the issue because they
don't want to see the issue discussed
and we have to discuss these issues in
order to deal with them well have you
been in contact with Colin Kaepernick
Kevin he hasn't reached out did you ever
think of reaching out to him yeah I did
but it wasn't possible he was probably
under a lot of pressure at the time when
was this when when this was all first
happening like I was first happening
last year and I also talked to dr.
Edwards you know but it's this is a
Kaepernick's way of bringing attention
to an issue and people don't want to
acknowledge that Kareem abdul-jabbar
here in the Rich Eisen show studio does
what is happening now remind you of the
late 60s at all and absolutely I
remember in my own case right after dr.
King was assassinated I was involved in
a demonstration on UCLA's campus and
people came up to me while I was
standing there and said hey you're going
into the NBA what are you complaining
about you're gonna have the opportunity
to make a lot of money and the the two
issues do not relate you know what I was
protesting about the assassination of
dr. King was quite valid whether or not
I was going to have an NBA career and
people have to get their heads around
that because whatever they might say
those were the facts
but we're not talking about an
assassination of an individual right now
so we're talking about a lot of
individuals who have been killed under
very very rickety circumstances let's
just say uh anyone who saw the beating
of Rodney King should understand that
these are serious issues I've watched
that film cops seem like they were
having fun they could have killed him
they weren't really concerned about that
and this has been the attitude of too
often too many police officers so we
want to see that change well I guess I
should have been a little bit more
articulate that it we're not weren't
talking about an assassination of a
slain civil rights leader so you believe
what is happening in our society has has
created an environment that is similar
to when you in Muhammad Ali in Jim Brown
Bill Russell to name just obviously a
few from the sports world were socially
active when we were active that at that
time it was still impossible for black
Americans to vote in many districts in
the south and there are a lot of things
that needed to be dealt with legally so
you know what we had to say was was
valid and the reason that dr. King was
assassinated had to do with the fact
that he was challenging those
circumstances and encouraging black
Americans to resist and to overcome
those circumstances so these things are
related Mycroft Holmes in the Apocalypse
handbook a new comic book by Kareem
abdul-jabbar again that's a book that
we'll be talking about again here
shortly on the rich eyes and show you
how the graphic my bad a graphic novel
oh and you just handed me when it's it's
autographed of course Thank You Kareem
that is remarkable and I want to talk
about this in a moment but obviously the
issues of the TV in a way if you don't
mind the word Trump everything else
right now yeah what do you think of the
warrior
stance that they were appearing to make
not going to the White House to see
Donald Trump what did you think of that
I thought that was a great way for them
to use their platform to show their
disapproval of mr. mr. Trump's
activities some of the things he said
his embrace of the Nazi Party and white
supremacist I would be very alarmed if I
were gonna go see someone who had those
attitudes so III don't blame the the
Warriors at all and it's hard to hard to
disinvite somebody after they've already
said that they're not coming I guess
they were about to do that officially
but Steph Curry had made those
statements that they appeared to so he
did disinvite them what what's the way
out here Kareem I mean is there one cuz
I mean there's so many people who were
listening to us right now and I'll be
honest there are some listening watching
us who would love us to get off this
topic just talk about sports and I do
want to know your thoughts on Lonzo ball
later on to just get down to that but
all that said this moment in time
certainly in the sports world was this
agenda was set by the president on
Friday night when he said what he said
right and there's so many people who do
listen to this and want to hear the rest
of this conversation and listen to it
and watch it they want to know how can
we get through this how can this be a
situation where everybody does get along
correct I think we have to start talking
to each other and we have to start to
deal with the real issues that we have
you know the the people that went to
demonstrate in Charlottesville had there
were real issues anti-semitism
discrimination a woman was killed you
know trying to demonstrate based on some
real issues and the president seemed to
ignore that didn't even attend a woman's
funeral I think that that really showed
where his sentiments lie and
sometimes I wonder you know how it makes
any sense so you're saying a cream
abdul-jabbar here on the Rich Eisen show
studio you were saying that that his
comments on Friday with that as the
backdrop is what is yeah it's starting
to appear that he doesn't doesn't get it
and that that should worry a lot of
people so where's the dialogue come from
that a dialogue has to come between the
left and the right all the different
factions in our political universe here
in America we have to talk to each other
and find out who we want to be and how
we want our nation to come across to the
world have you reached out to LeBron at
all about this or anybody else well I've
spoken about I thought LeBron did a
great job because he spoke about the
issue he didn't try to escape the issue
he's talking about the real the reality
of life in this country when I saw him
on ESPN him and Chris Paul and Carmelo I
thought that what they had to do was it
was focused it was not hysterical and it
was to the point what do you think dr.
King would say if he was alive today
well I think dr. King would appreciate
the fact that a lot of black Americans
have understood what nonviolent
confrontation of foreign racial issues
is all about and that's how we have to
deal with this let's take a break we'll
come back we'll talk about your graphic
novel okey doke
and why and what got you into Mycroft
Holmes and I know you have a book this
is not your first Mycroft Holmes tome
that you have put together exactly
Kareem abdul-jabbar is here and then I
do want to hit you a little bit on the
upcoming Laker season and anything else
that might come to mind you've got
that's Kareem abdul-jabbar here in the
Rich Eisen show studio your phone calls
844 204 rich we will take him don't you
dare worry about that along with Stefon
Diggs of the Minnesota Vikings that's
all still to come
you take a look at this graphic novel
Mycroft Holmes in the apocalypse
handbook and you'd think the last person
who would be behind this and have his
name at the very top as the author would
be Kareem abdul-jabbar and yet this is
the case check it out right now in your
local bookstore and available at the
Barnes Noble where again that the Grove
here in Los Angeles this Thursday Kareem
abdul-jabbar will be he's here for a few
more minutes on the rich eyes and show
how did you get into this stuff right a
whole lot of comic books when I was a
kid yeah like which one's Batman
Superman the flash Green Hornet okay
sure
all the standard ones a few Donald
Duck's in there nice right and you know
just has something to read it it's the
thing that gets me about comics are it's
a different genre you only have a
limited amount of space and you have to
tell the whole story
mm-hmm with pictures in this limited
space so it's a it's a total different
application but what about the Mycroft
Holmes story that you obviously yes yeah
yeah that was a Victorian novel it's the
tone and the the speech in a setting is
totally Victorian mmm-hmm kind of like a
orthicon in Doyle Yeah right wrote
Sherlock obviously do you watch do you
watch the Sherlock series on BBC do you
check oh yeah the ones would Jeremy
Britt
yeah and Benedict Cumberbatch and those
yeah I've watched all of them do you
like that yes starting with the one with
Basil Rathbone okay this is your deep
into the Sherlock Holmes yeah from one
culture when Saturdays used to have
Sherlock Holmes theatre and you know all
my boys we'd get together and watch it
right and in in TV show and the sherlock
TV series Mycroft is his brother is
basically an mi6 shadowy character it's
an interesting update of the Holmes
story well that's how Arthur Conan Doyle
described him in the book I think it's
the Greek the Greek philosopher thought
excuse me the Greek professor hmm I'm
forgetting the story but he's someone in
the government
at times is actually the British
government mm-hmm that makes you wonder
exactly what that's about but it's not
really clearly defined so it was
something I could use you don't just let
my imagination go the graphic novel
again everybody can go get it online or
at a bookstore near you Mycroft Holmes
and the apocalypse handbook before I let
you go
Kareem LeBron James was speaking for the
first time since he put out a video and
then a and then a Twitter a tweet where
he called the president a bum for
disinviting me warriors this is what he
had to say
moments ago before the Cleveland
Cavaliers at a podium we're not gonna
let I'm not gonna let while have this
platform to let one individual no matter
to power no matter the the the impact
day that he should have or she should
have ever used sport as a platform to
divide us she take it at Kareem well
that's what you'd call a freaking tooth
speaking truth to power and I'm glad
that LeBron did that it shows that he's
dealing with it in a very mature and
effective way and I hope he keeps
speaking up
he's 10,000 points behind you on the old
time points list give or take a free
throw or two do you think he's gonna
catch it
Kareem well he could I mean I think he
might get bored and you know just retire
and go to an island and spend some of
his money but he has a good chance at it
and if he does it more power to him you
know he's been a very classy individual
and whatever he does I'm a fan have you
met Lanza ball yet if you ever cross
paths with him I yeah I didn't meet
Lonzo earlier this year he seems to be a
nice kid I hope he can overcome all the
hype that's been created by his dad and
you know have a decent season that
that's gonna be hard thing to live up to
well I mean going from UCLA to Laker
them you know all about that do you
think that he has what it takes well in
this town he's absolutely a talented
athlete but it takes a while to learn
how to play the pro game it doesn't just
come easy but you know it's it's great
that he has the opportunity that he has
and we'll see what he can do with it
have you met levar have you chatted with
him yet oh no ever what would you say to
him if you had a chance I don't know if
I'd get a word inside with but if you
could get a word in sideways what would
you say to him Oh some of the things he
does puts a lot of pressure on his kids
and in other ways it attracts attention
to them and you know if they can deliver
his athletes it's all good so you know I
that's the for him and his family to
deal with on that that's all I'm gonna
say about it but he he can definitely
fill up the air with words that's for
sure okay last minute I have here what
do you think Muhammad Ali would think of
today's times if you were alive today to
see it oh I think Muhammad Ali would be
concerned but I think Muhammad Ali would
be happy to see all the people that have
learned from his example that we got to
go out here and change things if they're
not going right so I hope that's what
happens well I appreciate you coming in
here today Kareem you are welcome here
any time I'd love to have you any time
that you are up for coming in here well
I'll be right terrific I appreciate that
and Mycroft Holmes and the apocalypse
handbook a graphic novel yes okay is
right here in my hands and it's not the
sign one here I'll show the sign one for
the television audience because that's
the way he rolls all the best
abdul-jabbar thank you so much Kareem
abdul-jabbar Mycroft Holmes and the
apocalypse handbook check it out right
now online or at a local bookstore near
you the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience
isn't it amazing you can download an app
with your thumbprint you should download
our app with your thumbprint